all right from the top and the trophy  action  we are in Nashville and we are shooting  the music video for hold on today  hold on is all about life on the road  and just missing everything that home is  whether you're a soldier come at home  whether give them at home is your  parents or your grandparents a long time  whether it's your twin brother who  really annoys you and you still have to  come home and see his face yeah you love  it  these typos homecomings are real come  home you haven't seen anybody in a long  time it's just really nice to see your  mom and dad and all family gathered  around yeah this is really showing the  real deal  drew actually carries a 90% of the  weight in this case he plays and sings I  just show up and look pretty they're  trying to work but everyone keeps going  we do miss home as much as we love what  we do and everywhere that we go we also  love coming home to family you better  rest because we have a whole other day  tomorrow